hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar uterine b cell dynamics during
pregnancy
immune regulation of the placenta i'm
susie valdez of labruts and i will be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckmann coulter life sciences
to learn more visit them at beckman.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting as many questions
as you want during the presentation to
do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
and if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers
continuing education credits please
follow the process to obtain
those credits by clicking on the
continuing education credits window
i'd now like to present our speaker
marilyn benner
a phd candidate at radboud institute of
molecular life
sciences marilyn welcome you may now
begin
your presentation
thank you so much for this introduction
welcome everyone to my presentation i'm
glad that i get to tell you some more
about the placenta
an organ most people don't like to think
too much about
but i want to share with you my
conviction that there is a lot to learn
from an organ that defines
how all of us were born i'm marilyn
benner
i'm a phd candidate of the reproductive
immunology group
of dr van der mullen in nightmaker in
the netherlands
this webinar was sponsored by beckman
call to life sciences and they hold no
responsibility for
what i will present to you today
i first want to introduce you to the
placenta and why to consider its
immunity
reproductive immunology is the field
that focuses mainly on immunity of the
placenta
and in the following i want to show you
why we do this
so the most prominent function of the
placenta that we probably all know
is nutrient exchange so the placenta has
to establish this connection of
mother and the baby and aside from this
very direct connection the placenta also
offers a safe environment
for embryonic and fetal development so
you see here that with its membranes it
kind of forms a cocoon
selectively allowing passage of certain
factors
whilst prohibiting entrance of others
placenta formation means that fetal
cells grow
into the uterine wall and this already
sounds quite invasive
so how is this possible and we look at
this
in a bit more detail
salsa fetal origin of this villus tree
here of the placenta
they let go called
extra virus trophoblasts then and they
can
crawl further into the uterine wall
so everything you see here on the right
side is maternal tissue
so the maternal uterine mucosa and there
are spiral arteries
so local vascularization of the mother
and these
extravastrophoblasts they settle in the
blood vessels here and then
allow blood to flow between these villi
so the interval of space
and whatever nutrients need to be passed
on to the baby can then be taken up
by fetus by the fetal bloodstream
and you see that this invasion of
trophoblast cells
this connection with the mother is
crucial and otherwise the whole placenta
cannot be formed correctly
and for this to happen you need
interaction of
fetal and maternal cells so this is
quite complex
so imagine what happens if this vascular
connection cannot be established
properly
the unburned baby will suffer from
nutrient shortage
and thus growth rotation can follow
and this doesn't only affect the baby
but it can also
impact health of the mother
it is also the cause of preeclampsia a
common pregnancy complication
which affects quite high incidence of
women worldwide
preeclampsia or pe causes amongst others
very high blood pressure in the mother
and dangerous kidney problems that can
lead to lifelong disease or even death
in a severe type of pe known as help
syndrome the liver is also affected
and when pe or help get severe doctors
are faced with a decision to deliver the
baby often too
early for the baby's development to be
completed
in order to save both mother and the
baby
so you see that there is a lot of impact
from this process of spiral artery
remodeling
so in short we cannot underestimate the
importance of the placenta
however we have to keep in mind that the
fetus is composed for 50 percent of
paternal genes
so here comes why the immunology of the
placenta is so important
the question is how local immune cells
of the mother
allow for invasion and recognition of
fetal cells
and we still know very little about
which
cells interact in what way with fetal
cells
so the general quest in reproductive
immunology is to understand the
mechanisms of regulation
that are involved in this placenta
formation
how is this mismatch between maternal
and fetal cells tolerated
it is important to know that the uterus
is full of immune cells
and these cells are not generally
silenced for example they are still able
to eradicate
incoming pathogens to understand how
this works we look at these local immune
cells
studying their phenotype and also their
frequency
of different cell types needs to be
studied and ultimately
we want to understand the function of
these different immune cells and how
they contribute to healthy pregnancy
only when this is known we can develop
early detection and treatment options
we've previously studied the phenotype
and composition of immune cells before
pregnancy
from the non-pregnant endometrium and at
the end of pregnancy
upon delivery
by isolating immune cells from menstrual
blood
and this is an acknowledged method to
obtain lymphocytes from the uterus
without the need of a biopsy so we know
that these cells that end up in the
menstrual blood
represent local cells of the fetal
maternal interface
different to systemic cells and likewise
we isolate
cells from the maternal layer of the
placenta so here you see the deciduous
parietalis
that holds the maternal immune cells and
we consider these cells the counterpart
to the cells of the endometrium
but then at the end of pregnancy
we studied these cells using flow
cytometry so we get an overview of
markers that each cell expresses
to translate them to a particular cell
type
and we observe that by pre-pregnancy
so here you see the menstrual blood
cells
they're mostly naive t cells the t cells
isolated from
placenta so here in black
contain more memory t cells
so we see an increase in memory towards
term
next to this increase in memory
throughout gestation we could confirm
that these t
cells increase in general while nk cells
peak mid gas station and we know this
mostly from studies
that focus on a specific cell type or
specific time point as well
so this is a nice confirmation that this
parallel approach
is a good way to to study this
however all these studies use different
isolation techniques
and we cannot easily compare percentages
of cell types or even marker expression
between them
so while we know something from
literature what happens in the meantime
it's hard to deduce the dynamics from
the different studies
and we don't know when uh when induction
or inhibition of a particular cell type
takes place
and of course there's a lot that can
happen during nine months of pregnancy
and now
we only looked at the beginning or at
the end
so this leads us to a next question what
happens in the meantime
so based on this we then moved on to
study how the local immune environment
is changed throughout gestation but
before moving on to the focus of
this presentation and the study which
are b cells
i want to show you something on the
general immune composition
and how it changes throughout pregnancy
so similar to the approach you just saw
next to the previously discussed tissue
so from menstrual blood and from
term we isolated cells from the mucosa
during pregnancy
using abortion material so using these
methods we can now get meaningful time
points all throughout pregnancy
and all of these would otherwise be
discarded
all these different types of tissue so
there's a lot to learn without even
having to take a biopsy and we can still
look at the local immune environment
so we then characterize these the immune
cells we isolate from all these
different tissue types
and we processed all of them immediately
immediately
and identically so we performed flow
cytometry
using standardized panels and
we can then focus in more detail on the
different phenotypes
again we confirm these fluctuations you
just saw so for example
in k cells they arise until mid gas
station and then there's less of them
for t cells they are much lower in the
beginning of pregnancy
and then they increase in frequency
during gestation
a small frequency of these t cells are
regulatory t cells or t-rex
and they also increase throughout
pregnancy
we also looked at the general increase
in memory similar to the approach that
you just
saw
so you see that from non-pregnant
endometrium to first and second
trimester
and k cells so here and k cells rise and
then decrease towards birth
t cells rise in frequency from first
trimester
to term
and trx gradually increase during
gestation
however while many studies on immune
regulation focus on t cells and their
regulatory capacities the other main
cell type to mount an adaptive immune
response with possible regulatory
capacities
has not been characterized throughout
gestation and for the rest of this
presentation i will focus on b cells
so up until now b cells and the uterus
are only considered signs of infection
and our research question was in how far
b
cells are naturally part of immunity at
the fetal maternal interface
we first use flow cytometry to show that
b cells are present in the non-pregnant
endometrium
and then in placental samples throughout
pregnancy
and you see that compared to peripheral
blood or even menstrual blood
b cells of the deciduous so that's also
what we call the mucosa during pregnancy
the uterine mucosa sorry
um there the frequencies of b cells are
very low
so this makes it harder to study these
cells in vitro and functional assays
but we can zoom in on the different
subsets by more detailed flow cytometry
analysis
and for this we now move away from
supervised skating towards the
automated clustering method
so why do we do that so mostly we
we have our flow cytometry plots and we
draw gates around
our events but i guess that a lot of you
who do this a lot
and attend this webinar for this case
are familiar with flow cytometry
and that also means that you know that
analysis can be a struggle
so you can manually define
characteristics of a cell type
and flow cytometry and this is based on
literature
so you manually draw these gates because
of
what you read but also your experience
you know that
in a certain plot your population is
always at
a certain position so you draw your
gates around them
but of course this is extremely
subjective
and there's also a proportion of chance
right if you don't copy the gate
settings from
your previous analysis and you start
start drawing a gate from scratch
it might just end up at a slightly
different position so
it can be a little bit lower or a little
bit higher and the
borders change then also the frequency
changes
so in this general example you see that
when a t cell is cd3
positive and cd6656
negative we consider it a yeah a t
cell but then the question is would that
bother me here
or like where we draw it now or maybe
slightly higher maybe slightly angled
and this gets even worse when you don't
know what markers to select for so you
are more open in your approach
and if you look for cell types rather
than the frequency of a known cell type
so where you
have an a priori idea about your
phenotype
so if you don't have that if you want to
look for something new
then it becomes very hard with this
subjective way of gaining
and in that case automated clustering
can help to identify which markers
clustered together
so imagine i measured expression of
marker a
b and c so in the different channels you
have
available for your flow cytometry
markers and based on literature i focus
my analysis on cells expressing
a and b or
b and c unsupervised clustering can
identify that when considering
all samples of a given and given
analysis a group of cells
with the same characteristics can be
observed so maybe
they express a combination of markers we
previously didn't look at so here
marker a and c they were not part of our
initial question
but there's still a possible combination
of markers
so this is not that big of a problem
when we have three markers
so few and if it's only a question of
yes or no expressing that marker so very
black and white question
however a cell type can express a marker
to different degrees
so maybe a subset of cells is a positive
to a low degree for a
and kind of somewhere in the middle for
b and c
and then it has some high expression for
a and low degree
for b and so on
so um this is then just a small overview
of how from from these
six options you can move to uncountable
options
because we would not be able to to
differentiate between a certain
low and medium or high expression
so unsupervised analysis which
determines the characteristics of a cell
type especially suited
here in our question because we don't
know if the mucosal cells
follow the expression patterns defined
by by the use of cells of peripheral
blood so
these characteristics that we normally
know from literature about a certain
cell type
they might not fit with what we know um
oh sorry with what we observe in uterine
cells
so we have to be a bit more open in this
approach
thus to study our mucosal lymphocyte
populations we move to an unsupervised
clustering method
and we use the citrus tool of the
cytobank website
so we upload all our flow cytometry
files and the tool assesses
if there are um different uh clusters
based on the cells from all samples
assessed together
and it looks then um to find these
clusters uh
themselves of its or itself
and you don't select these subsets
the output are these nodes of cells um
expressing a particular marker
and you then get the overall abundance
of this marker
um in the in the data set so for each
uh each marker you're studying you get a
different
clustering tree based on these color
codes
for all markers we can then define how
each node corresponds to a certain cell
type so
this you do manually by um looking at
the different expression patterns
but the notes and the different subsets
uh there's nothing manual to
to do that you just have to then
afterwards assess marker expression and
yeah if you want to couple it to a cell
type um
you you'd rather these borders
and this strategy showed that samples of
uterine mucosa contain b cells
so here you see their characteristics
cd19 expression
and they also express hladr
so then the most common classification
of b cells
is to look at whether they are naive
memory or antibody producing
so for this we first checked with the
standardized flow cytometry approach
now that we've seen that b cells are in
in all of the
samples present
here you see that from pre-pregnancy to
term
uh cells become less naive
and more of a switch memory b cell type
is observed
you can also see this gain and memory in
a cd27 expression
that's considered a marker that is
generally upregulated after b cell
activation
and the previous analyses focus on
mucosal samples
so we only looked at the sigira or the
uterine mucosa and
now we want to know what makes these
placenta b cells special
so to do that we have to compare them to
peripheral blood
and we need to include b cells of the
circulation to do so
so for this comparison we now move uh to
the unsupervised analysis again and we
can really
make most of it where we previously just
focused on is this a con
confirmation can we use unsupervised
analysis to detect these b cells and all
of our samples
we can now really harness its power by
focusing on
phenotypes that we might not see by
manual
gating so we don't predefine the marker
combinations
but we just asked the algorithm to show
us different clusters
and next to this identification of
clusters the cytrus tool also shows
clusters that allow for classification
so you can check if the subpopulation is
characteristic
for one type of sample that you include
in your analysis
or the other one so you can
first of all examine different
phenotypes of markup profiles we don't
know about this unsupervised analysis
but there's also strength in this
analysis by
already telling you which features of
which clusters
and subpopulations allow for
discriminating between a certain type of
sample
we observed that there are four clusters
of b cells that are absent in proof of
blood
but that can be found in temps of the
placenta
so almost nothing here in the peripheral
blood samples
but um more frequencies of these
cells during gestation
and it goes a bit far now to describe
the different clusters in in detail
but they show phenotypic markers that
are associated with regulatory
properties
so in the end we were wondering
is there a regulatory phenotype involved
here so
would these cells have some kind of of
suppressive function
so these are the profiles of the cell
types
um and without looking at these
histograms of the markers in too much
detail
you can appreciate that it's not just
about whether or not a marker is present
or that but about the the slight
differences
in in expression so
it's not so much about yes or no but
there can be
absence low medium or high expression
and we would not have been able to
identify these differences based on
supervised analysis
so after observing this phenotype that
is often
associated with suppressive capacities
we then moved on to
a bit of functional analysis and we
wanted to see if these cells are in fact
regulatory
and the most common way for b cells to
be a tolerogenic regulator
is to produce il-10 an immune
suppressive cytokine
and indeed when we compare peripheral
blood
and then cells b cells isolated from
deciduous we observe more potent il-10
production
next it would be interesting to know
where these cells are located
and then it might also give us a hint on
whether this il-10
has an effect on neighboring cells but
this is very hard to study
in in vitro so it's very hard for us to
isolate enough b cells and to then
perform co-culture
with t cells because of their very low
frequencies but we can study tissue
in histology and then look at
look at the structure where do we find
these cells
and what you see here is that the cd 19
positive b
cells here in yellow are located next to
t
cells so cd3 positive
in red and you can see some green fox b3
staining
so every now and then which is
characteristic for regulatory t
cells and
you can also see that these yellow b
cells often cluster
together so they're not really scattered
throughout the tissue
but in close proximity to t
cells so it would this be possible for
the locally
secreted ielts 10 to have an effect on
the neighboring cells
and here you also see that the nk cells
and purple
are a lot more abundant so it's um
really a
question of finding the needle in the
haystack here that you
you do observe these these yellow cells
especially
that the because of the b cells
clustering together
um you really have to find the right
spot so where are these clusters
um in your whole placenta and you only
put quite a small selection of your um
mucosal sample
in on your on your slide so you don't
have the whole placenta covered
so there's also a bit of luck involved
to to observe these clusters
for t cells of the placenta there's
already way more evidence that they
contribute to healthy pregnancy
so even though you only see very few
cells here are very few of these b cells
they might still have an effect on these
t cells where we know that they are
important
so b cells might form an important hub
of interaction
and this brings us to our overall
conclusion
so even though there is not many of
these decidual b cells
they might still contribute to the
overall pattern of local immunity and
pregnancy
i would like to thank everyone involved
in this study the biggest
thanks goes to our donors more than 200
women helped us out to make this
possible
thanks also to batman culture life
sciences for sponsoring this webinar
and of course to to all the colleagues
all the gynecologists and the
uh contributors from different
departments who made this possible
i'm happy to take any questions uh and
now and in the live uh in the live
session
i'm looking forward to interaction and
uh also feel free to get in touch later
on
so um maybe you cannot join the live
stream
no can i join the live session no but
don't hesitate to
send me an email thank you
anything you so much marilyn for that
informative
presentation before we begin the q a
portion of our webinar
i want to encourage all the audience
members
to participate in the poll that you
currently see
up on your screen
and following this poll we will begin
our live q a version of the webinar if
you have
any questions you want to ask please do
so
now just click on that ask a question
box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as
many questions as we have time for and
thanks again for
participating in our poll so let's begin
our live q a we have quite a bit of
questions already coming
in our first question
um marilyn is what about
il10 production by b cells
isolated from term issue so
at delivery uh
perfect thanks for that question um just
making sure that you can hear me
yes yes perfect all right so
um yes we tried looking at il-10
produced by b cells from term
however the problem with term is that
you only manage to isolate
quite a few cells in general quite a few
lymphocytes
and then the percentage of b cells
within that sample is quite low so in
the end
uh there's unfortunately just a very uh
low number of cells so we we try to to
look at that but in the end we cannot
obtain enough events to yeah consider
that a reliable result so unfortunately
we
we didn't include it um yeah because of
technical problems as well but it's also
uh the question then how relevant are
these cells if
if we almost find none of them anymore
at term
thank you so much and marilyn you didn't
know if these women had a healthy
pregnancy can you still assume that
observations
are relevant for a healthy pregnancy
uh yes indeed we don't know that so
unfortunately there's
a lot of data we don't have on these
women it's all very anonymous tissue
but we still assume that a large part or
the major
the majority of women who donated are
healthy so we
we do ask questions on the health status
and we only ask women to donate for us
if they um they uh
how do you say that they are not part of
the exclusion criteria so
we know that they didn't have infections
at the time point or
um any other form of drug abuse or
anything that might be a problem
for us thank you so much now one of our
audience members has a question about
cell isolation do you know if cell
isolation affects
marker expression uh yeah that's an
interesting point so
i'd encourage anyone who does any kind
of isolation from tissue to
check different enzymes and what they do
on your tissue so
we also describe it in the method that
we use two different kinds of enzymes
depending on what our
aim was so for example we use
collagenase and to
to obtain quite some cells from from a
sample and it's very effective
to get a lot of cells however it also
affects your marker expression so
you have to be careful about that we
then use a different enzyme called
acutase for
phenotyping because we see that um yeah
marker expression isn't affected that
much
and yeah that's preliminary uh sorry
primarily an issue for um chemokine
markers
so it's always good to um yeah check
what your enzyme does and
if maybe you need to switch in case you
see a large effect or a lot of a
certain marker thank you so much
now our next audience member says
congrats on your
excellent presentation i have two
questions please
do uterine b cells produce antibodies
that
enter the system systemic circulation
do they contribute to the shift from th1
to th2 response
in normal pregnancy
thank you so much for your question as
well um
so yes these uterine b cells might
produce antibodies and we try to
check that however um the the
concentration is is very low and
it was a challenge to measure this
because also the serum that we culture
ourselves
and contains a certain degree of
background antibodies
so um unfortunately i cannot give you a
very precise answer on this
um we don't know but you need to
consider that the
amount of cells present there is still
um yeah
quite low so we wouldn't say that they
um they do that much
on the systemic immunity of the mother
probably but in a personal opinion i
would think that what they do is mainly
locally
and i think there was another part of
the question concerning
th1 and th2 balance i think that goes a
bit in the same direction so
um probably um what these
b cells might do um is done locally and
um
yeah there's the the th1 th2 discussion
i think it's both both um
yeah discussed systemically or in the
uterus
and um i think the view of shift is
shifting a bit so
it's not only about th1 or th2 anymore
but
about which cytokines are involved at
what time point
do we really have a lot of information
going on and um
i think we are now more looking into
different different cytokines and if we
then look at
um the il-10 produced by b cells that
might have an effect
on the cytokine production by the local
t cells so
yeah unfortunately i also cannot really
say for sure what the effect of t cells
are at the moment like i said uh at the
end of the presentation
that would be the next step to bring
these cells in co culture and then
see if they can really functionally
affect t cells
thanks for the question and thank you
now did you have access to any
preeclampsia
or other pathological samples
that's a good question as well so um
pre-eclampsia we
um we did uh get some term placentas
from that so and then again we get the
discussion on
term placenta there's way uh fewer cells
we can isolate from that
um and at least we could phenotype them
and instead of then moving on to the
functional assays
however um we we did see a shift in and
phenotype there that
looks different from healthy tissue but
then um
i'm not sure if i stress that in the
presentation enough we
um isolate cells from term from
c-sections
because then we consider that labor
hasn't started yet and hasn't had
a lot of effect on the phenotype of
cells we isolate
so um the pre-eclampsia placentas we got
often label was induced or they they
were from uh
normal deliveries so then um we checked
afterwards that this um if this change
in profile of b cells
was related to preeclampsia only to the
normal delivery
uh instead of a c-section and indeed
in the normal deliveries we also saw
this changing profile so unfortunately
we couldn't really uh control for that
we we couldn't get
um uh c-section placentas from
preeclampsia or at least not enough to
to really say something about this
thank you so much marilyn and i want to
thank our audience for these
great questions coming in these are
fantastic
now do you think that the il-10
producing b
cells migrate to the decidua
during gestation or that they
differentiate or expand locally
uh yeah that's an interesting point to
discuss as well so um
regarding b-cells in general i think
there's not quite some evidence that
they are
present in the uterus independent of and
also prior to pregnancy
so um we can isolate these pieces from
menstrual blood for example
as you've also seen and there's also
more data
of earlier studies supporting that b
cells are a natural component of the
mucosal immunity of the uterus
and now there's also quite some studies
uh showing that extra villostrophoblasts
or
placental explants can stimulate il-10
production by b cells and also there
were some
studies showing that cpg can
stimulate these b cells to produce il-10
so
if these cells are already present
locally and we know that then um
yeah we have implantation and extra
virus trophoblastic waiting
we have local exposure to cpg upon
pregnancy
there might be a local differentiation
going on so
um yeah that's also of course just
speculation but that's something um
yeah we can envision at the moment thank
you so much
our next question endometrious plasma
cell detection
in endometrium is there any relation
between detection of b cells and plasma
cells
um yes so i think and in the case of
endometritis we would see
way more b cells and we did have a few
samples where the percentage of
uh b cells and lymphocytes in general is
way too high so
what is way too high it's a lot more
than what we normally see
so yeah after all these isolations of i
think now more than 300 percenters in
the end
you um you have a feeling of how many
cells you you normally get and
if that was um above this usual level
then
we didn't consider or we didn't study
these cells further
as now we only focus on healthy
pregnancy
thank you very much now marilyn have you
characterized the expression
profile of these il-10 producing b
cells and based on unsupervised
clustering do these il t
10 plus b cells cluster together as well
uh yeah that would be very interesting
so there are studies from peripheral
blood where
you can kind of capture the il-10 on the
outside of the cell
and then they um earlier studies did
some
sorting of these cells and also then
some analysis but unfortunately these
um cells we have now alpha and producing
b cells
are so few again that we we couldn't do
that for now
um but in a future single cell analysis
that would be interesting to
uh yeah really select only these il-10
producing cells and then
yeah study them in more detail
now are the b cells present in the
placenta
fetal or maternal and is there
immunogenic learning going on
within the uterus um
okay so two questions b cells present
and the placenta feta are maternal
so we uh right now only isolates the
maternal tissues so we consider what
is a continuum kind of from menstrual
blood endometrium samples
uh through first and second trimester we
um
we selected mucosal tissue that we then
i think is tissue from the mother and
especially with the um
first and second trimester samples um i
don't think at that point there's
um or does sorry
the fetal membranes didn't fuse with the
maternal membranes yet so
whatever we have at that point uh is
really maternal
and also for term samples we do select
only the citral parietals so the
maternal
layer of the placenta um
is there immunogenic learning
i think that's um that's an interesting
point and that also our group focuses on
especially now for nk self and um
yeah we we didn't look at that for for
business until now so it would be
interesting to then
uh follow up um b cells maybe from
menstrual blood samples of
women who have been pregnant and then
later on check if their b-cell profile
is different because they have been
pregnant before and um
yeah maybe this kind of fades out at
some point as well
and uh yeah we don't know so in the end
it might be interesting to see if uh
locally there's some kind of memory of
these b-cells as well
thank you so much we have time for a few
more questions
what role do nk cells play
and this is a two-part question does the
fetus have
nk cells sometimes in development
um yeah so there's a lot of work done on
nk cells and they're the most prominent
cell type
in these procedural samples so um i
think i can
refer if you want i can somehow send
around um some great reviews on that i'm
not an nk cell
expert um but there's um yeah a lot of
um a lot more studies on ik cells and
that's also
uh kind of why we focus now on these b
cells because
and k cells and t cells are such a big
focus but um
it might also be this very small
population of cells that that still
contributes
um and as the fetus have nk cells
and i think this is also um
yeah a different part of the discussion
so if you want to look at uh
mk cells there's there's a lot of great
work out there
and um yeah that's really uh um
yeah the biggest uh the biggest amount
of information you will find on
reproductive immunology
so um yeah maybe i don't know if there's
some way i can
distribute it but otherwise yeah feel
free to get in touch and
i i'll refer to you work from people who
really know a lot about nk cell
wonderful thank you so much we have time
for two more questions
how do you know that you look at uterine
cells and not
contamination by peripheral blood
uh yeah that's a good question we often
get asked because
um yeah it is um it is an important
thing to consider we did check this
especially for
our encases as well because they're um
we
we have some markers like cd 103 where
we know that they are
then considered tissue resident cells or
if they lack
um cd62l they are not associated
with circulating lymphocytes so we we
did check these markers for nk cells so
that we know that
um even for these big cell populations
there is no contamination
for b cells there is not that much
strong marker profiles where we can
really say okay if the cell expresses
these markers we can consider them a
tissue resident cell
but there's now some studies focusing on
i think
gut resident b cells who set up kind of
a marker profile to check
if a cell is resident um however however
then we also wouldn't
know for sure if the same market
profiles would be seen
in uterine b cells so um
i think also the um the unsupervised
analysis you saw
was the biggest evidence now that um
cells we isolate from uterine mucosa are
really typically distinct
to adjusting from peripheral blood
thank you so much marilyn and we have
one final question for you
why did you choose to study b cells and
not
other types of immune system cells
uh yeah that's a good question so um i
think we we just discussed that a little
bit
um basically because there's not a lot
of information about that
and it might still be important so it's
a bit overlooked and most information we
see on
uh not the most information but a lot of
information still says
that um presence of b cell is
pathological and we just wanted to see
uh if this is really the case um or if
we if we do
bcb cells in all our samples if we do so
i would be um nice to to just
include them a bit more in the
discussion um and like we said there's
now a lot of evidence on k
cells and t cells and that's a strong
focus but um
yeah maybe even though it's just so few
numbers these b cells
do contribute to the overall immune
environment so
yeah it was uh um venturing into
a new cell that kind of marilyn i want
to thank you for your time today
we really appreciate it and would you
like to provide any closing remarks
before we go
uh no thank you this was really nice
there was a lot of discussion i
received a lot of questions and if
there's anything else you can
contact me i think my email address is
visible somewhere
so feel free to get in touch thank you
so much
and i want to thank you again marilyn
for your time and for your important
research
and i want to thank lab roots and our
sponsor beckman coulter life sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast and before this
i want to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be reviewed on
demand
laboratories will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time stay safe and
stay healthy
take care everyone bye